foreign
welcome to the data science Hangout
if you're joining us for the first time
today it's nice to meet you I see a lot
of familiar faces so I know a lot of you
have been here before the data science
hangout is an open space for the whole
data science Community to connect and
chat about data Science Leadership
questions you're facing and what's going
on in the world of data science the
sessions are always recorded and shared
to the YouTube as well as the rstudio
data science hangout site which we can
share in the chat here too so you can
always go back and re-watch or find
helpful resources too
we do also have a LinkedIn group for the
hangout if you ever want to continue a
discussion with someone or ask feedback
or see a summary of the past week
sessions I will encourage people to post
them there and start conversations so
it's not just me talking there but uh
together we're all dedicated to creating
a welcoming environment for everybody so
we love when everyone can participate in
these sessions and we can hear from
everyone no matter your level of
experience or the area of work that you
focus on
there's always three ways that you can
ask questions so you could jump in by
raising your hand on Zoom you can put
questions into the zoom chat and feel
free to just put a little star next to
it if you want me to read it out loud
instead or I can call on you to
introduce yourself and add some context
too
we also have a slido link which I'm sure
Hannah is sharing here in the chat where
you can ask questions anonymously too
I am so excited to be joined by two
co-hosts for today for the first time
ever today we are joined by Derek Beaton
director of advanced analytics and Jamie
Beverly director of product development
at Unity Health Toronto
I would love to have you both introduce
yourself and maybe tell us a little
about a bit about each of your roles the
organization and maybe also something
you like to do in your free time outside
of work
uh Derek do you want to start first
sure sounds good
um
so I'm Derek the director of advanced
analytics in a group here called data
science and advanced Analytics
um uh the overall group and I'm sure
Jamie and I will share different details
on this it's a
a data science unit in Unity Health
Toronto which is three different
hospitals here in the city
we have four different teams across the
data science and advanced analytics team
Advanced analytics is the team I'm part
of Jamie's is the product development we
have a data engineering team and a
project management team
um
for advanced Analytics
uh uh my team uses lots of exciting
tools less exciting tools to understand
data um bringing
um predictive analyzes to different
clinical problems or different uh
resource problems in the hospital
scheduling assignments
alerting a whole bunch of different
things
and we're diving into kind of new
domains including Medical Imaging and a
few others that we can chat about a
little bit
um yeah and then I guess for me
um stuff I like to do I like to go
running I like to go hiking my
internet right now is probably very bad
because I'm actually at a cottage and
I'm about to go hiking after this
so far so good but I'll let you know if
it gets choppy
thanks Derek Jamie do you want to
introduce yourself
sure yeah thanks
um yeah I probably don't have the time
to uh to vote broader structure of our
team so I'll uh I'll talk to my
particular team the product development
team within data science and advanced
analytics
um so our team
is more focused on the software
engineering and design side of things so
not so much data science but once we
have a model that's developed by Derek's
team
um how do we get that model uh into
production and into a front-end better
end users use
um so for doing that uh we work a lot
with um sort of HTTP apis like wrapping
models in Plumber or flask or fast API
um and then building front ends it's
shiny or react or some of the other
platforms that are supported on our
studio connect
and then we also do some design work so
creating mock
-up um
converge towards enzymes
um right about uh my sort of like
background and interests
um
I was more sort of on the humanities and
cultural studies Science and Technology
studies side of things in school and
then pursued a masters in Computing to
get more oriented towards the software
side of things
um
um so for those kind of meet now I feel
it's uh in the computer interaction
and then in my free time I spend a lot
of time with music stuff I have uh World
synthesizers beside me here
cool thank you both so I know this is
the first time we've ever had two
leaders on together so I thought it
might be good to ask
how both of your teams work together and
how you started to have this this great
relationship
um
and why it's so important that both of
you are on the hangout together
we actually have uh three of us here on
the call we've got a soft in the
audience here as well
um
uh something there uh I can maybe start
there
feel free to have comments
um so uh Derek mentioned we're kind of
comprised of four teams uh which starts
at
um uh our data integration governance
team
um which is is led by Sheldon here so
composed of um
data Engineers ETL developers
um did a governance specialist uh all
the folks who
know how to get the data from a very
messy
Legacy Source systems into a format
that's accessible for both modeling and
for real-time applications
um
and then once we have data in those
formats that's where Eric's team does
all the work on the modeling side of
things so training models on top of that
um and analytics and Reporting and then
uh once we have a model that's sort of
ready for for deployment in a in a
production application across in one of
our hospitals that's where my team comes
in to build those front end
um and then there's a fourth team uh
that's composed of uh
project manager
manager there
no that covers it that's really
yeah
I guess one point to add to the project
management team our um
our VP Muhammad is uh freely reminding
us that data scientists aren't good at
the management part so the project
management team are fundamental to
making sure
we we can get done what we do
that's great and seven I I didn't know
you were joining us as well as a special
uh welcome to you thank you for joining
from the team as well if you want to
jump in and introduce yourself
uh yeah uh well I I I'm not one of the
speakers I'm actually here to listen but
then I was pulled hi my name is shivnam
I'm the director for data integration
governance at data science and I'm
analytics I've worked with Jamie Derek
and our uh indispensable project
management team uh yes Derek is right
and Muhammad is right
we need somebody to keep us in sync
otherwise we would probably fall apart
uh what I want to add to Jamie's really
good summary is that
um
the things he talked about like getting
the data modeling and then front-end
development it kind of looks like a
linear process but it's not actually
it's there's a lot of overlap so once uh
as soon as we start
uh looking at the data Derek's team
starts looking at the modeling
possibilities where Jamie's team starts
looking at the deployment options so we
kind of work in parallel and it's the
project management team that actually
kind of makes the pieces click together
so that's why we have to keep in touch
all the time with great communication
that's great it's a party here
everyone's here thank you for joining as
well I see uh Niall you asked a question
in the chat do you want to jump jump in
and ask that
sure it's pretty uh simple but maybe you
can go into some more depth I'm just
curious about how your teams are
managing ml Ops you've got these models
in production
you know how are you monitoring them and
then does the uh you know the user
development and product development
teams play a role in creating that
monitoring process or is that you know
fully with the advanced analytics group
I'll jump in for part of this
um so
on a lot of the monitoring side uh we
have
I think I think a a lot of it is on our
side for now where we have a lot of
reports that come out to us we're
building a dashboard to actually
centralize all of our different
deployments so we can watch what's
happening with data model performance
any sort of drift or changes
um
I would say for a lot of uh the ml Ops
type things we're mostly focused on the
practice as opposed to any particular
tool sets right now but we are
trying to Rally behind quite a few tool
sets
um
I think a lot of these are largely out
of the uh some of the the movements
we've seen recently in like vetiver and
the other like R Studio packages that
are coming out from Julia where
monitoring uh monitoring models getting
model cards
having these quickly accessible to us is
where we're moving
um
and we're moving in this direction
because I think
there's been a significant expansion in
a lot of what we do across a lot of
different a lot of different data
sources in the hospital with a lot of
different problems whereas like earlier
on
I think before my time and maybe someone
else wants to jump in on this one a
little bit more focused on subsets of
problems and subsets of systems
um
yeah I don't know if that really answers
your question but but I'll toss it over
to uh Jamie and shebling too to jump in
um
mostly process oriented right now but
rallying behind tools
yeah I would Echo I think what they're
once they're like I think we're we're
kind of growing in that domain still
rather than figuring out what
that's like for us and I think
simultaneously partly like overwhelmed
skeptical and uh excited by all the
things out there
um uh you know lots of things that run
on a kubernetes cluster that we don't
really have the
the use case to have a massive
kubernetes cluster
um
that that said I'd say we have a pretty
core set of requirements for most of our
projects where we have
a model we want a version that model
uh we want to save predictions all the
predictions at that model generates we
typically want to save some data
alongside that model
we want to have monitoring on all the
predictions that model generates some
states to a database
and and we want to host those models
behind some
um HTTP API typically
um so those those set of criteria I
think are
you know good criteria for engineering A
system that can handle our use cases
um
but yeah I think um a lot of the tooling
some of the tooling that we've seen out
there is either like
for yeah run on a large kubernetes
system that we don't have a use case for
um
uh so I don't know we've been building
some things in-house also I think
exploring that ever recently
I I think it might be helpful to all put
us in like the mindset of the problems
that your team is working on what is an
example
use case across the hospitals let's
start with like um one of our flagships
uh uh chart watch so it's an early
warning system for deterioration
um
that uh from
the advanced analytics side so that one
um models were developed a while ago uh
they're wrapped up for
uh uh Jamie's team to help deliver like
alerts
um we get our pipelines from shepnam
scene and then on the monitoring side we
have fairly frequently updated reports
on what is happening
um when alerts are sent out when
uh or what kind of model performance
we're looking at so a bunch of different
metrics to see how this early warning
system is actually working on a regular
basis
and can you just expand on it for me
what is the early warning system mean
um so uh if if individual patients are
potentially deteriorating this will send
an alert off to clinical teams uh that
are
set up in the alert system or those that
are there that day to get an alert that
a patient needs more attention
okay so that's taking all so taking all
the data from chevron's Team your team
is working on creating that model and
then Jamie's team is deploying that
model did I get that
works well right
he's got a few other um
in most cases too which are so I'd say
there's like a suite of tools we have
that are around this like kind of
alerting about a patient uh use case we
also have a few that are
um we're focused on optimization models
like
generating schedules for for nurses uh
very complicated and Rule played in task
and we optimize that to
like reduce number of times that an
earth assigned to the same location
as an example
so so optimization models uh working on
medical imaging as well so detecting
your cranial Hemorrhage and dicom images
um uh traumatic brain injuries and other
projects
yeah another kind of Suite of other ones
that work more on the chart record
it's really interesting I see um there
was a slido question about the early
warning uh
Flagship product what kind of models do
you use are these some calculated
metrics or some kind of predictive
models
they are predictive
there are a whole bunch of candidate
ones a long time ago and then we
we
um landed on one of the best performing
ones
um and
fairly recently
um this this early warning system has
been moved um uh
away from us and to a company that we're
collaborating with but it is it's
predictive modeling
thank you Mark I see you just put a
question into the chat do you want to
jump in
sure yeah I was just wondering I I know
from personal experience that uh
Healthcare is pretty
um slow to to update to more modern
tools so we end up with a lot of uh
technical debt I'm wondering how you
um like can you go into more detail
about how you integrate some of those
Legacy systems with some of the more
modern tools that you're using
um is it like workarounds or is it kind
of like pipelines into
um
kind of wondering what your approach is
there
I think I'd better jump in at this point
uh so yeah
our data
our Hospital systems are very fragmented
and no we are not on Epic so we don't
know if this place these things play
nice or not we're going to find out in a
couple of years I hope we we don't we
are looking for a new EHR we don't have
one yet so may or may not be epic I'm
not really sure right now what we have
is pretty old systems and uh we started
we actually started the journey by uh
having coded pipelines the where code
was attached to the modeling code so the
first piece of code goes into the
systems pulls data merges it cleans it
up and then passes it to the model
um which was not really good honestly
because uh the same kind of information
say the patient's temperature is
relevant to like 10 different models so
we would be pulling that same
temperature for 10 times
for each patient which overwhelmed are
already old and overwhelmed systems so a
year and a half ago I guess we invested
in
um logical data warehouse a data
Federation system where we pull the data
cache it for a little while until the
next poll until the next scheduled pull
and all of the models are getting their
data integrated cleaned up harmonized
data from The Logical data warehouse the
Federation system
does that answer your question
yes it's kind of just from understand
it's kind of like a staging Warehouse in
between
sort of yes so it's a it's a smart AI
support that actually smart Federated
system so it optimizes queries on the go
we can pull data on the Fly for not so
frequently use systems or Cache the data
for the systems that we use frequently
and we can do all kinds of uh data
haggling in there so yeah you can call
it a staging
uh layer between the actual data and the
models
okay I see Travis you had a
similar question or a follow-up question
I know the part about epic was answered
but do you want to jump in
yeah intriguing like Mark
um asking from a place of experience
with a couple large Hospital Systems
where
um epic or Cerner type products don't
tend to
integrate well with with more modern
applications like our studio products
let's say or um even you know flask
um type python things
um and so we've had ml teams trying to
produce outputs sounds like you solved
the input problem well enough with like
this sort of staging area that's that's
a cool solution because that was another
thing um you can't really hit the live
database of the EHR system because
that's needed for inpatient care and if
you hit it with a large model things
will fall over and bad things happen
that's cool staging Works um but then
once you produce the model how do you
get it back in front of the Care team
like the physician or the coordinators
um if it's not a fire for like uh like a
pop-up firing thing inside of Epic or
other EHR system they tend not to see it
and they tend definitely not to want to
go to uh like a second browser window or
somewhere else to find information
because they simply don't have time for
those things um so how do you how do you
solve like the accessibility portion at
the Clinic side
a few thoughts to add to that I think
an unsolved issue for us as well we try
a lot of different things for different
projects and a lot of it is kind of
project dependent um
so yeah our older Legacy systems we it's
it's
typically pretty hard to get any kind of
data into the systems
so there are times we have to
we do have to you know provide a
separate website that in some cases we
can link from the EMR
um
uh in some cases we can actually embed
kind of actions within the EMR so if
they
were exploring we're doing this for one
of our Medical Imaging projects actually
where
um if a radiologist is within a viewing
tool viewing at a CT scan that can hit a
shortcut on their keyboard or right
click and click a button that will open
with contacts to our website passing
um and then that's another domain
control
um but it's I think another concept like
alerting is especially
uh perhaps challenging because there's
there isn't really a consistent alerting
approach across the organization
um some units of the hospital will have
uh you know designated cell phone that
they provide to the elite nurse for a
shift on another unit they don't have
that or
um it's you know the resident has an
application on their personal phone
that's rated to for you know secure
information and we could Target that
um but it's it's very heterogeneous I
think that's something
um we try to
um
it's very hard to build like engineering
instructions around that that
um
I guess one other
tool we've we've been developing over
the last
um a year and a half it's uh it's called
our Operation Center which is kind of
um an in-house Hospital Command Center
type tool similar to
um to some of the market products that
are out there
um so it's a a place that folks in the
hospital can go to see patient flow
information or patients are admitted
discharge transferred
um census of current patients and their
their needs which is all fed from the
EMR systems but it's our own front end
so we've kind of
developed that as a
front-end platform where we're hoping to
centralize a lot of our analytics
outputs so it's not uh it's not too
different dashboards you have to go to
for your uh for our like data science
outputs and
predictions but can be at least just
kind of one uh centralized tool
to add like a little bit more to that
too
um we work really closely with uh the
individual like clinicians or clinician
groups that that or other staff
um on understanding what might work
um so there is a lot of customization
that will come from like Jamie's team
um and in other cases sometimes it's
really tricky to get
um say like uh some other website or
some other alerting mechanism that's
outside of the EHR so
we call in for help from other teams
that will help uh handle like what this
means for individuals with these deploy
tools so how do you get everyone up to
speed how do you get them trained how do
you get that information back out there
and we also rely on basically um
uh
kind of leaders that that are on the
other side of these projects so the
people that come to us with these
projects
kind of have to be the Champions
um to then get everyone in their their
units or their groups to be on board
with
what will actually go in place
yeah that's a interesting point a good a
good workflow it sounds like because on
the other end if if you on the data
science side it seems to me if we see
problems that we know we can solve and
then we solve them then you have this
extra layer of work to be done which is
go around and Champion it to everyone
and advertise it um and I I don't I
don't love being in marketing as much as
just solving people's problems that they
know that they have
I think that was a topic a few weeks ago
how
you also have to kind of be the sales
person for your own tools
I see
um
Alan you had a question and I agree with
you yes the range of use cases is really
fascinating do you want to jump in and
ask that
uh uh yeah sure
hey everybody
um I think I'm I'm mostly just reacting
to the breadth of things that you're
describing that the team works on from
stuff that's operational to like really
like much more deeply clinical stuff and
then Super step super technical stuff
like Imaging and it's a really
impressive range and so I wonder uh you
know
I imagine that that within the team you
probably don't have the like domain
expertise
um to be really deep in a lot of those
things so how do you get the partnership
that you need and this this may stem
from
um this may sort of Bounce from from you
know the last comment that Travis was
making about you know champions of the
of the work and stuff so what does that
partnership look like and what does
um uh because there's it's something you
have so many customers understanding
like who to work with and when given
limited resources I've got to think is a
challenge sometimes so this probably
gets to the the project management team
that you work with but also speaks I
think to like how are you situated in
the organization such that you're the
place where the work comes to like at
the right time you know strategically
how does that work
um you know thinking just all those
aspects of like how do you
operationalize projects coming in and
doing work that that people need
um so I'll speak a little bit about some
of the data and analytics part where
um
we so on on the team actually across
like several uh all of the teams we do
have some like subject matter experts
that have experience on the other side
of data science
um
um so we we have like a really a diverse
group of of people that have
a lot of experience in this domain
um and uh I guess going back to the
previous point about the the
Partnerships when when
clinicians or staff or other individuals
in the hospital
um in the network come to us
um
we require really like a lot of time and
we spend
um uh quite a bit of time like working
out the early parts of the project
um frequent working group meetings to
make sure that both sides are in very
frequent communication
to ensure that the technical the
clinical the operational sides are all
in touch and actually
understand
the problems with the data or the
problems that we're trying to solve and
say some of the challenges of bringing
some of these things to deployment
and and like another small note here too
I guess building off of um
like the breadth of stuff here we all
kind of have like little mini teams
inside our teams too I think it's fair
to say sometimes the mini teams are like
one person
um but we have like little mini teams of
of uh expertise within each of the teams
I'll put this maybe add to that briefly
um
so just started to call it explicitly
like yeah all the projects we work on
um originate from from our end user
groups from those clinical Champions so
we have like an intake process and then
take form
um so our end users come to us with this
form folder where we ask
um you know what's the current state
like what's your what's the problem
you're trying to to solve
um what's your desired future State
um what kind of metrics would you
measure to
um to say whether we've improved on
something or if we've gone the opposite
direction it made it worse
and then where data science fits into
that it's not all objects are solved
data science
um
I think that's kind of uh if a luxury to
have because we don't have to but we
have very engaged clinical
um
end users and
um we don't sort of have to do that
sales pitch at the end of a project
um just as Derek said there's lots of
time invested from the clinical side so
we've saw you know inherent interest
Ing and successful
I may add a few points about the
prioritization part you asked uh so we
are a strategic part of the hospital we
are not research so uh being in the
hospital as a part of the hospital puts
us under the Mandate of the Strategic
objectives of the hospital so when we're
uh deciding on prioritizing the pipeline
of work that is coming to us as Jamie
and Derek mentioned we take into
consideration stuff like feasibility and
things but then we also evaluate them
based on the strategicals of the
hospital and then we have uh two
criteria are we improving patients
outcomes or are we improving Hospital
efficiency if a project does none of
these we just don't touch it
foreign
thanks for all those I really appreciate
all those different lenses on that on
that process and hearing more about the
organization and
um uh how things work gives you a bunch
to think about with respect to our teams
here thanks
yeah I thought that the outline there is
is really helpful too like how you get
the projects from the clinical Champions
like what's the problem you're trying to
solve what's your desired state
what sort of metrics I think we could
all use that regardless of Industry
I see
um there was a slido question from a bit
earlier Anonymous one could you give us
some idea about the scale of your
operation so like how many models and
how many data apps do you currently have
in production
13 in total is about 30 right now that's
including the four four times
and um in terms of applications we have
production I think
like 30 or 40. and projects on the go
right now
say eight to ten is that about right
that sounds about right yeah
and um I know something that
that we talked about previously was
one of the like eye-opening moments for
you is when you your team discovered you
could publish react applications and I
was just curious of the use cases that
you described which is the one that's
using that framework
yeah I can I can speak to that so
um I I kind of came from a more software
engineering like full stack
um background where the ACT is pretty
ubiquitous
um
we were developing this um operations
center
uh project and
um we were originally developing in our
shiny and then Felts that we wanted to
leverage some of
um some of the react ecosystem for one
particular component uh we used a
what it is there's a shiny Widgets or
something similar
um our package that lets you author
react components and find them as shiny
widgets to use in shiny applications and
we were using that
um and then
um
that was really doing the bulk of our
kind of UI front end complexity and we
decided okay might as well just write
this in react and then
so yeah I'm not sure why it took me so
long to realize you could do this but
this I discovered you could uh deploy
react applications stars do you connect
and have them talk to
talk to guys just with
um like Venture quests
um so so our front-end stack now is like
a typescript yeah
I think API requests
which uh that we find to be
nice
awesome
I'm going to check to see some of the oh
for one of the the slido questions there
was for legacy systems integration do
you depend mostly on custom scripts or
third-party platforms and add-ons
for scripting what's your preferred
language and why
I think I
can take on that uh
for legacy systems as I mentioned
earlier we are using this
data Federation
tool and
I think we can we managed to connect to
almost all of our Legacy systems
other than one that was very badly set
up so even the vendors themselves
couldn't figure it out
so for these one-off cases where we
can't actually use the Legacy system we
we either go with r or python go to
Pipelines
scripts that run on a server and then
feed into either the model or the
um logical data warehouse itself that's
also possible
thank you
Travis I see you just put a great
question into the chat there do you want
to ask that
sure
um I think we all have these I was
asking can you tell us a good cyber
security says no story and how you got
around it um this is particularly
prevalent in Hospital Systems um
I guess without further color I'll just
leave it at that
I'll toss over to both show me and Jamie
in a minute but it's not many no's
because we do a lot of stuff completely
internal so we're on
we're in the data center we're on this
infrastructure that is approved by it
and security
um where there's some no is some some
Cloud stuff
um and it helps to have uh liaison
or spy someone from our team on uh
tightly connected to
um it and security
to make sure that we know what's going
on and we have frequent communication
with them
that's interesting so who does that
liaison typically be like I like that
solution
um do you have like a designated person
who is I'm the person who convinces
cyber to say yes
uh yeah actually uh I have system
administrators in my team apart from I.T
because uh the hospital is mostly a
vendor shop but our team inside is a
Linux Island so we have our own sys
admins and one of our sis admins has the
task of keeping our relationships with
the rest of the hospital in a very
pleasant level
thank you
um and uh you may have realized that my
title is data governance data
integration and governance so uh we
actually took over the data governance
portion
in the hospital as well so we are
managing that and that's kind of helps
us do what we need to do in a safe and
secure way while uh
also helps us getting less notes
extra work for extra permissions if you
want
that's great I see Richard Richard you
said you do that exact same thing I'd
I'd be curious to
to hear a little bit more from you too
yeah it's uh very similar actually
strikingly similar I'm in a large Home
Care Agency in in New York city that is
integrated with a health plan and a
hospice
and a long-term care system that's
managed at home and a lot of the no's
that we have from cyber security have to
do with cloud
you know having data having to cross
that boundary uh get translated from uh
you know one virtual environment to
another
but uh yeah so our Cloud engineer on our
team sits on the cloud engineering uh uh
uh
you know all their conferences for the
larger i t Department I worked inside a
data inside of a data science department
in this organization so he sits in both
roles as the as the liaison and keeps us
on board with what their concerns are
and vice versa and that way we in data
science don't try to do a lot of things
that we know they're not going to go for
and so that's that keeps us focused on
the things we can do
and uh kind of keeps that friction to a
minimum
that's really interesting so is that was
that person originally part of your team
or was originally part of the larger
part of our team yeah we did about four
years ago a big kind of lift and shift
from a data center to the cloud and uh
that's that and so we had
a foot in that on both sides we ended up
insisting on having an on-premises
server for this very problem you know
because we knew we would have this
problem and we got that and so I'm the
person that manages that uh on the Linux
admin in a window shop that manages that
and then our Cloud engineer who works
with me as my backup on the on-premises
server he manages the Linux Cloud
instances and so he's in there
their uh you know all their security and
change management meetings and that's
enough of a pipeline for us to kind of
stay out of each other's way
but but he's a member of our team okay
thank you that's really helpful too
um Robert I see you just put a question
into the the chat with a few acronyms
that I do not know so you might have to
explain them
any kind of uh about them um if you're
not using anything like that um I'd be
curious to learn about what you're using
yeah I think it would be me again
um
we do use hl7 not fire yet given that we
have Legacy systems uh for those who
don't know aa7 and fire are actually
um communication protocols between
Healthcare Systems so it's a messaging
system hl7 not only lab records
everything else actually uh hl7 is more
text-based while fire is more uh
semi-structured based Json XML
um we do have our hl7 system but we are
not using any external tools we actually
just grab the messages that we're
interested in and press them ourselves
so it's in-house
um something that is related to those
where we
have some there might be some hl7 in
there if not there will be fire in the
future
um in our Medical Imaging
um uh platform that we're building up
we're using something called xnat xnet
is a big Suite to help organize a lot of
Medical Imaging data and projects
that is one uh very specific open source
tool that we're using to communicate
with the Imaging systems and the
different scanners that that are
available
um
that's not a specific messaging tool but
they have embedded in there a lot of
different messaging protocols like Risk
packs
risks for communicating with packs
I believe they're going to have fire in
there soon but I'm not positive
thank you
I see somebody asked on slido I'm
assuming you use the rstudio platform
but before that how did you manage
dependencies for example package
versions
I think that was before my time
everyone was pretty good at it when I
when I got here we're getting better
yeah
um
yeah I guess I mean we're all of our
projects he's our ends very heavily and
Honda
stuff for
yarn for JavaScript
and uh yeah our studio package here as
well I'm not sure
so so sorry I I I'm the oldest on the
team and yes we invested in our studio
uh very early on so I don't think we
have anything that's not deployed
through our studio
of one version or another
accidentally pushing sensitive things to
the cloud or to get up or others
um Jamie the audio is a little bit
hard to hear but I think it maybe is the
headphones I don't know if you want to
try
um unplugging or using the computer
audio but it might maybe it's just on my
end is this any better yes uh
yeah we use gitlab on premise too that's
all
okay awesome
um I just I had a question as a
follow-up from when you were talking
about
um the whole conversation of like on
premise or in the clouds are there
someone's at the door UPS
um are there any use cases from anybody
on the call as well where you have both
like internal applications that are
behind a firewall but then also other
applications that may be exposed to like
the public
or other stakeholders
Jamie might be muted that's sorry I
think we have one such deployment
um we developed a tool a while ago for
um
predicting Ed volumes
that's a number of patients waiting in
the Ed
which we we deployed at one of our
hospitals actually two of our hospitals
and then
um
also created a deployment for a hospital
outside of our Network
um
that's the one that was running in a
Docker container in a special part of
our infrastructure that we could open up
to um
uh you know to the internet to be
accessible from from this other site I
don't know much of the specifics about
how how long that was configured though
I think we had something on shiny apps
okay yeah that that's really interesting
that's a question I hear from
uh quite a few community members
sorry Derek
the shiny up one I think was more of a
calculator right so yeah I don't know if
it actually had any data I think you
could provide your own data to it
um
that being said I do think there are
some things coming up
in the future where we might see some
things that become semi-public-facing
now stay tuned
okay thank you and all those and will
those live in a separate
but easy to wait you're not an idea is I
don't know like architecturally speaking
how does that happen
um because Rachel that's a great
question and it's definitely one of the
Cyber says no areas that I've never
found a good solution to in a hospital
system
um they usually say even if there is no
data in this application we can't make
it outwardly facing because it's running
on our servers which then do connect at
some point to our data so they want to
stand up like a whole new infrastructure
to host in some cases what is an
entirely computational simulated like
calculator or something like that
um so is that is that what you all
strategy is or is it different
uh correct me if I'm wrong
public facing or uh external facing
applications are running on a VP lens
I think that's correct yeah
I'm sorry I don't know anymore
no no worries
um and just curious and then what what
was the term you said it's VP so it's a
virtual uh private lab okay so it's I.T
and security managers it to their own
satisfaction and we make use of it
so reducing the friction between us I
see thank you does that operationalize
is it's like a highly restricted IP a
set of IP addresses that can access the
application is is that how that I don't
know that much about that particular
framework
uh well neither do I we should have my
assistant one of myself that means at
least here but I think you are correct
yes I I can connect you to also's admins
if you're more interested in learning
more though
that's interesting yeah
um so now it sounds like not fully
public facing yet like where someone
could go to a URL and actually attempt
to log in and fail if they don't have a
credentials it's actually they have to
be ipy listed first
yeah I I think it's not only IP
whitelisted but uh also has
authentication tied to it but I'm not
really sure about the details
interesting thanks
I'd be happy to help connect you offline
too
um I see there was a few other anonymous
questions I wanted to make sure I got to
as well thank you thank you all for for
your insights one is if you would split
your projects into analytics first
predictive modeling first one-off
reporting and Analysis what would those
percentages look like
so I can repeat those two so analytics
versus predictive modeling versus
one-off reporting
if we go with I would say what we're
currently working on it
okay
Let's see we have the resource ones that
are one off
a couple dashboards
um
it might be a third or third a third
right now uh maybe before
there were
maybe more analytics and a few
prediction algorithms and
the occasional one-offs
but certain groups well so some of the
one-offs are a little unfair to call one
off uh we've got like repeat projects
that happen every so often because the
frequency of that kind of report so like
the nurse resource team that we work
with um they need some type of one-off
report but they've needed it several
times
um usually as things change as
Staffing changes as budgets change stuff
like that
um
right now I I don't know uh
Jamie Chapman does it feel like a third
or third or third right now with the all
the new ones coming in
well if you count the you know
uh and not seeing stuff like that as
one-offs yeah it sounds about right
I'd say like um
a lot of the projects that start off as
predictive intended to be predictive
modeling or analytics projects
sometimes end up at reporting we kind of
have
two phases to two large phases to our
project process where
um the first first phase which we can
kind of promise to our end users that
come to us is that we'll do the
diligence explore the data
um assess feasibility of modeling but if
we end at that point and just find that
there there's not enough data to build a
predictive model then that project
really ends
report or and we may see it to the end
users too like you know if you collect
XYZ over the next year or two come back
to us so we can try this again
um so uh
that's sort of another back to the
second part of our project process that
would be if we have the positive signals
that a model is viable then
um
building a product
I know there were a few questions on uh
model monitoring and there's actually
another one here too so I wanted to
mention I just put into the chat but
next Tuesday we actually have a Meetup
with a customer so care who's presenting
on model monitors and alerting at scale
and for some of the questions asked I
thought it might be of interest so just
put it there if you want to add it to
your calendar
but the question in in slido is how do
the model monitoring so data model drift
look like in your work what tools do you
use and what kind of metrics do you look
at
covet ruined everything
um
so anything that was before
covid uh covet ruined everything
um
uh so we see different types of drifts
there we see it with waves
um what we're monitoring in terms of
like metrics is more Project Specific so
we don't have like a singular metric
um in many cases
a lot of like the predictive algorithms
are it's very important to have a good
um
uh
good basically good performance uh to
avoid like false negatives or to make
sure you're capturing true positives so
we'll focus on like ppv and npv
false positive true positive false
negative rates but there's no singular
way of doing this
it really does depend on
what
what kinds of metrics and what the
problem really dictates so we do have
different ways of monitoring different
models
which is why we're trying to bring it
all into One dashboard right now too
that's some work we're doing behind the
scenes where
try to bring a lot of these in one spot
so that it's a little bit more
centralized
instead of living in inside of each
project individually right now
thank you
I see um Niall you had asked a really
great question earlier that I missed and
love to go back to that on the team
structure if you want to ask that live
sure
um I I'm interested in some of the
benefits and
um
detractions of having the teams broken
out the way you do if you feel like
they're
yeah your thoughts on it and also if
this was something you any of you helped
create and and part of that process
um we sort of got a One-Stop shop team
structure and um it sometimes works and
sometimes I'm asked to do things I have
no idea how to do so yeah curious about
your take
I can add like a few comments maybe
about
like how it Formed maybe and uh someone
attack me if I say anything that's wrong
but the team started I guess
said like four years ago roughly
um and it was primarily or entirely data
scientist so I believe the original team
was like three or four data scientists
um more positioned within research
and then the
second team to kind of grow was was
shednem's team so the data integration
governments building out the data
warehouse
um
following that I believe we
realize the need for project management
that's that kind of formed organically
and then the last to join was mine to be
focused on
design and
um
yeah I'd say
um
I'd say that the structure works works
fairly well for us I'd say there are
like there there are places at the edge
of edges of our teams where I I think
we're still kind of figuring out what
that uh
what that looks like there's some
questions about mlops earlier and I
think that's sort of one space that like
touches
modeling it touches State Engineering it
touches software engineering
um
are not really sure where to pass that
ball
um
further
let's
yeah I just want to add that until
uh I don't know
how long have you been with us Jamie
Derek I think until that time like maybe
probably like two three years ago we
were actually one big happy team
with no distinction with no solid
distinction between modeling and data
engineering and product development uh
but then we had a lot less projects like
and we were like all of us almost were
track of all trades but then the number
of projects just exploded once we were
moved from Research into the hospital as
Jamie mentioned and that's when we had
to
kind of delineate some of the
responsibilities because being jack of
all trades means actually you have to uh
context switch like every three minutes
or so which is not productive at all
I was brought into go ahead go ahead oh
I I just follow-up and you said it was
one big happy team before but what was
the the process for splitting out the
teams
uh strength yeah
yeah we mainly uh divided ourselves
based on our strengths so
yeah that's uh and the project
management uh was at least our project
manager managers who was with us from
day one which is a really big Comfort
yeah absolutely I see Alan just
commented on that too and said it was
really interesting to hear how the PM
team was relatively early in the
formation
yep definitely um
Derek uh sorry just cut you off
it's okay no I I was gonna say that I
was brought into the team um with this
structure already in place
um I've liked it I've liked uh
compared to how I used to do things
before I'd have to like shivner was
saying like do lots of things all over
the place um it's nice to have that
Focus
um but as Jamie said especially around
like ml Ops where it feels like we maybe
are missing a little something
is like Bridges and hooks between the
teams uh for like those critical points
in
in
um like development or monitoring or
maintenance where it's good to have
people that know a little bit of
say two sides instead of trying to have
someone that understands everything
um but we have quite a few people that
are interested in like crossing
different domains and expertise across
our teams
the time for more uh translators
between everyone
um there's one other question I know we
just at the top of the hour it's okay if
I ask one more
um someone asked uh Curious I think you
mentioned Docker do you use Docker or
depends solely on our Studio's
versioning in which cases do you use
docker
probably speak to that and start off
um so
I probably use Docker as a catch-all for
application containers but um
you may be using Singularity or obtainer
or something other than that
um where we're kind of interested
an NC use in Docker I think a lot has to
do with
um
reproducibility of environments so
um having your Dev staging product is
all kind of consistent and built for the
same image
also some of the flexibility it allows
with regards to like
stock and technology so it's
um
pretty
you know quick and easy to raise a new
service through a through Docker
container
um what we're figuring out how to do is
um orchestrate container that becomes
like the next kind of piece and not just
have a mess of uh static coded ports on
the
various servers in terms of versioning
um
I'm not sure
um
I'm not sure Docker has like a big
impact on on versioning like we try to
do everything through Source control
where
um I think trying to get closer and
closer towards infrastructure as code
um so anything such as a Docker file
that you can have Version Control that
defines how your environment is created
but
um
scaffold departments based on these
configurations it's sort of over
um maybe before
great thank you I just want to double
check that I didn't miss anybody's
questions I think I got to everything
that was on slido but again feel free to
raise your hand if there was something
that we missed too
thank you so much uh shebnon Jamie and
Derek for sharing your your insights
with us and and all your experience it's
awesome to see how all the the teams
work together to
if people wanted to get in touch or
reach out to you what's the best way to
do so is it LinkedIn or Twitter
either
I'll drop an email here too okay awesome
yeah LinkedIn is great I think it's on
the on your website already
yes it will be there too and uh we will
update with with uh shebnon's
information too so thank you so much for
joining as well
appreciate all the great questions too
hope everybody has a great rest of the
day thank you so much for joining us